hey you guys time once again
for flickers of fear now when i first
started doing this series not too long
ago
one of the main motivations behind it
was wanting to do
more jell-o movies because there are so
many of them that i wanted to talk about
you know among other genres as well but
i really really like jlla movies
and i felt like i didn't really have a
lot of scope to talk about them on the
movie retrospective because we only did
once a week
so one of the things that i wanted to do
going into this project was to do more
giallo movies and just get more of them
done in the genre
now that said i started out with kind of
a strange one maybe not one of the ones
because we have done some
uh jell-o movies on our regular
retrospective show we did a deep red
obviously we've done suspiria
but the thing about it is that i thought
i would start with one that was a little
bit more obscure and i guess you could
say
more of a lesser addition to the genre
for sure like a much later one
so today we're going to be talking about
lamberto bava's 1983
a blade in the dark now the italian
title of this movie
actually translates to something like
the house with the dark staircase which
whatever that works too but this movie
so i guess what the history of this one
was
was that lamberto bava was given this
film now he it was originally supposed
to be for italian tv and i think it was
supposed to be like a four
episode miniseries like it was gonna be
four 30-minute episodes
so he kind of had written it like
structured it that
at the end of every 30-minute episode
there'd be like a really
extreme kill or whatever and then it'd
be like a cliffhanger and then like
you'd see the next one
well he did that but then when he
showed it to the producers or the
backers or whoever was going to show it
on tv
uh it was deemed too gory for television
lucio fulche ran into similar problems
with uh
house of clocks i believe was one of
them he might have had more in that line
but uh you know that happened in this
case as well so basically the producer
said well why don't you just re-cut it
into
a single feature film and we'll just
show it theatrically or whatever so
that's
uh what lamberto bava ended up doing
now i will say that this movie
as i said it's kind of um if you're new
to giallo movies
i would not recommend seeing this one
because this is really not
you know it's a solid film uh but it's
not one of the better examples of the
genre it's not one of the real
iconic ones and like i said it's you
know it's kind of later because it
didn't come out until 1983
and i feel like giallo movies kind of
their heyday had been
you know early to mid 70s so by the time
the 80s rolled around
you know it was getting to the point
where they were getting kind of old and
tired
a blade in the dark actually has a
really lot of references to
other jello films uh particularly
tenebre
and uh you know it has some aspects of
maybe psycho
in there people have also said that it
was kind of similar to
blowout uh the brian de palma film so it
has
aspects of all these other movies and
it's kind of just
so it's a little bit of a retread but it
does have a lot of the
uh you know giallo tropes so what you
have here
is there's a a dude named bruno
and he is a musician he's played by
the dude uh andrea akapini i think is
how you pronounce his name he was in new
york ripper
the luchio folgi movie so he's a
musician
and he is working on scoring a horror
film
now the horror film is being made by
this uh woman sandra
and she is basically shows him like the
same scene over and over again
uh so he's kind of like trying to score
the movie from that
now interestingly this little movie
within a movie which you only see
like a few seconds of really stars the
kid who played bob
in luccio folgi's house by the cemetery
so as i said it's kind of like
six degrees of jala movies because it's
just kind of like
directors and actors they just keep
turning up and all of this you know i
guess because the film industry
you know in italy was kind of you know
not as big as hollywood i suppose so
you'd see like the same people turning
up
particularly in this one genre so she's
been showing him this movie that's
supposedly going to be really scary and
the first scene
is this dark staircase like leading down
to a cellar there's these three boys
one of which is bob from house by the
cemetery and
the two boys are kind of like making fun
of bob
i'm just gonna call him that because
he's scared of the dark
and so they have a tennis ball and they
kind of throw it down the stairs and
want to make him go get it
and then they start taunting him about
how about him being a female so that's
kind of like
which may seem really random it's like
all these little boys going you are
female you are a female but it does
actually kind of tie in
uh to the central mystery of the thing
so it's not completely at random
so while bruno is scoring this film i
suppose
that you know the director whoever is
producing this horror movie that he's
doing the music for
uh the director she decides that well
she wants to get him in the mood
uh someone wants to creep him out
so she rents this massive villa
which actually belonged to one of the
producers of the movie i guess
like in real life that's where they got
this house for him to shoot in
and so she wants him to stay there
because she's like oh it's kind of
creepy and kind of isolated so
it'll kind of put you in the mood for
doing the scary music
so he moves in there and
he's only there for maybe a day or two
and he's kind of like noodling around
like working on the score or what have
you
and then all of a sudden this strange
woman pops out of one of his closets
quite literally
which is one of the hilarious things
about this movie is that
as isolated as this villa is supposedly
kind of out in the middle of this big
like
landscaped garden which also they have a
creepy groundskeeper you know because
like you do but just random women keep
turning up
uh so just unusually the crazy thing
about
this this woman turns up literally pops
out of his closet because he hears
something
um there's like this weird whispering
like coming out on his recordings while
he's doing the
musical score and uh you know it sounds
like a woman's voice
and so so he's like kind of
investigating this noises this woman
literally pops out of his closet
now another funny thing about this too
she pops out of the closet and she's
like she was scared by a cockroach even
though they show it and it's clearly a
spider and throughout the rest of the
movie every time they refer to that
event everybody says cockroach even
though it was obviously a spider i don't
know if it was just some kind of weird
thing with the dubbing because i have to
say
the dubbing in this now if you watch
giallo movies um you know
that genre overall uh english dubbing is
usually pretty bad uh this one kind of
takes it to a whole new level but
this one takes it to a level where it's
almost like just
[ __ ] super hilarious again just
because
just because it's so terrible and like
the the random weird [ __ ] that they say
i don't know if it was like some
lost in translation deal or i don't know
i'll just i'll get into it a little bit
later but just like some of the random
[ __ ] they say that like makes absolutely
no sense
and it's just super super funny and it's
like i cracked up a couple times
watching this but so this woman that
pops out of the closet
notably does not ever tell him what the
[ __ ] she was doing in the closet
uh basically the only explanation she
gives is that oh i used to have this
friend
linda and she lived here like she was
the former tenant of the house
and uh you know i used to pop by and see
her or whatever but the thing about it
is that
i don't know like i said maybe i'm
overthinking it and it's like
you know [ __ ] like this isn't supposed
to make sense but even though
she said that her friend used to live
there and she used to come over
she doesn't know where the bathroom is
because then he has to
tell her like bruno has to tell her
where the bathroom is he is
strangely not alarmed that there's this
weird woman like just popping out of his
closet and not explaining why she's in
the closet and she's being like really
cagey about it but it's like whatever
okay
so the thing about it is that just like
a lot of gela movies they're trying to
set up
a whole bunch of red herrings so that
you don't know who the killer is
so you know you're led to believe you
know maybe this woman could be the
killer what's she doing hiding in random
ass people's closets you know what i
mean so
it's kind of like that however uh if she
was meant to be a red herring it doesn't
last very long
because she gets murdered like pretty
much immediately um like in the first 10
minutes of the movie
now the first couple kills in this i
will say are kind of they're not
super gory and they're a little bit lame
just because the weapon
is like a little utility knife you know
what i'm saying
like literally one of these things that
that is the murder weapon
and so much is made of the little click
click click nice blind doesn't do that
because it's broken but um
the little click noise it makes like as
the blade comes out so this is kind of
supposed to be
scary i suppose but so yeah so the first
couple people get killed with that
and there's also a really funny scene
and i think i've mentioned this before
on maybe some of my other
uh jala reviews is that there was a big
thing
in a lot of giallo movies and i guess
old horror movies in general not just
italian ones
but where a killer would be chasing a
woman
and the woman would just kind of stand
there and just kind of let herself get
killed she would just kind of stand
there and scream and be like oh no
even though she could clearly like run
or kick the dude in the balls or
whatever and they just never did that
so there's a little bit of that going on
at least like you know the closet girl
katya at least she does kind of run but
she's still
she still gets murdered um she she hides
behind a thing of chicken wire which
if you're playing along at home you can
see through so i'm
it's not like a real good hiding space
and but also she could have like kept
running but she didn't and then she just
gets like stabbed with this little
utility knife like through the chicken
wire
so you know it's not a real uh
noble end i'm gonna say for katya the
closet girl
so after she gets killed bruno still
doesn't know what the hell is going on
um
i will say that the first pretty much
half of this movie
is pretty slow in the sense that it's
mostly just bruno
skulking around his house wondering what
like where these
weird whispering noises are coming from
uh wondering what happened to katya
because she disappeared
um there's also a scene like after she
gets murdered and the killer is like
dragging her
you know out through the yard and it's
nighttime
and he kind of hears something so he
goes out there with a flashlight and
he's out there
in the bushes and her body is literally
like right there like at his feet
because they have a shot of showing like
her bloody face and then like his shoes
and he's just very deliberately going hi
i wonder
where katya went to she was she's right
there and he doesn't see it so yeah then
the phone rings and he turns around and
goes back to the house so
you know it's it's fun it's like a
little bit contrived i'm gonna say but
it's
it's funny in how contrived it is
because like i said
i guess jello movies in general have
these kind of contrived setups so
it's if you're you know used to the
genre it's not gonna bother you too much
but some of this stuff is just a little
bit too
like unbelievable you know what i mean
it's just like how could how could he
have not seen her body she was like
literally right there like at his feet
and it wasn't that dark outside but
anyway then it's like so
they try to set up you know so bruno's
skulking around the house for half of
the movie
there's whispers on his tape random
women keep showing up at his house
uh this other friend of linda's who's
you know the former tenant
this other woman shows up and to swim in
the pool
and then she gets horribly horribly
murdered and probably the best uh gore
sequence
it's not gory by today's standards but i
can see how it would have been too
way too gory for tv uh you know
especially like it's like a
knife through the hand and then it comes
out and it's like it's pretty nasty
um so she gets killed and then you know
just all these random ass
other women show up um it seems like
they're trying to
make you think that the murderer is
maybe giovanni the weird groundskeeper
because he's they have one scene where
he's because he's super into porn he has
like all this porn on his wall like in
his little
ground keeper lodge or whatever and um
there's one
just random ass scene of him cutting out
uh articles about presumably murders i
don't know if they're in italian um
so but it looked like they were and he
kind of had him pasted on the wall but
they don't really do much with that it's
like he's always kind of like sneaking
around the grounds and like watching
women
women undressing and stuff but you know
it
it seems like as red herrings go he's so
obvious that you know it's not him
i will say though and it's like this
came out in 1983 so i'm not too worried
about spoiling it
but from pretty much 10 or 15 minutes in
i figured out who the killer was and
what was going on
so because because they tried so hard to
make you believe
that the killer was a woman
like so for a long time they're like oh
well this linda person who used to stay
in the house like here's some of her
stuff like in the cellar
um she disappeared nobody knows where
she is
and then they kind of set up some other
ones too like they're like maybe like
bruno's girlfriend who is an actress
like she's
up to some shady [ __ ] like she's
supposed to be out of town she's
supposed to be in naples like being in
this play
and then she kind of like blew it off
but she didn't tell him she told she
told bruno that
oh the show was cancelled and all this
other kind of [ __ ] so she's not being
entirely truthful either so they're kind
of trying to set up like maybe it's her
um they have a scene where they try to
set up that maybe it's sandra who's
directing the the horror film kind of at
the center of this
so there's all these little like
attempts to set things up
but they're very obviously attempts to
set people up
as the murderer and you so you know that
it's not them
you know and also i found that since
they were trying so hard to
make you believe that the killer was a
woman it's like they very specifically
showed
you know women's shoes and like this
kind of
uh you know like a lacy blouse you know
with a lacy sleeve or whatever
and i was like the killer is gonna be a
man
in drag i mean that's obviously what
it's gonna be
and uh gotta say i called it so so it's
very much like psycho in that way
and i was like well it's obviously not
giovanni the groundskeeper because he's
too obvious he's like the porny
peeper guy so it's like that's not gonna
be him so the only other guy other than
bruno and obviously it couldn't be him
was tony now tony
you knew it was him one because he was
only like in a scene or two at the
beginning he was like the guy
i think that he owned the villa but he
was renting it out because he i guess he
couldn't like afford to pay for it or
whatever he made some kind of crack
about that
so he had been renting it out and he was
the one that told bruno about yeah linda
was the girl that used to live here and
blah blah and like there was all this
kind of stuff you know there was all
this kind of stuff about katya her
friend and like she had this diary said
oh linda's got this terrible secret and
i found out about it and yada yada
so you have the same thing where uh you
know just like a regular giallo you're
kind of like you have this
person uh you know who's a musician
and he's kind of thrust into the middle
of this murder mystery and has to figure
out what the hell is going on
while people around him are getting
murdered and there's also an aspect too
of he just keeps finding stuff around
the house like oh here's a
stab mark in the bathroom with what
looks like blood in it and here's like a
bloody tissue
so he you know and all these girls are
like disappearing
um which he thinks is odd so he's like
well there's got to be some murders
going but he doesn't find any bodies
so it does so there's actually kind of a
good reason for him not to go to the
police because he's like look i don't
have any bodies all i've found is like
some bloody tissues these girls are
missing i'm just assuming
that they got murdered because there's
some weird [ __ ] going on but i don't
know where the bodies are so i don't
want to
call the cops because you know they'll
think i'm not that i don't have anything
to go on
so there's that kind of whole issue too
so as i said
what ends up happening you have kind of
a psycho situation where
you find out at some point that the
horror movie that sandra is making that
has that scene
with bob from house by the cemetery and
the other two kids
um making bob go down into the cellar
and you know taunting him about being a
female
and you find out later that sandra was
had based this
scene on her friend linda's childhood
but what she didn't know and what she
found out later on
was that linda was not linda but linda
was tony so there's kind of this whole
thing where tony had some kind of
issue and it's like he didn't want to be
a girl child and so when he got
older he had a female
alter ego and he would dress up as a
woman
and kill women so like i said it's kind
of like psycho in that sense
fun fact the killer in this one tony
um who also played tony slash linda is
played by
mikele sawavi now mikely sawavi was he
was an actor in a bunch of
movies too but probably more famous as
being a director
and he directed stage fright he directed
the sect the church
and cemetery man one of my favorite
italian films of all time
which we actually did a retrospective on
not too long ago
uh so yeah so you get to see him in this
one
being a murderer and uh you know running
around and
a really weird like nancy reagan kind of
looking ensemble it was 1983 what are
you gonna do but yeah as i said if you
are just getting into giallo movies i
wouldn't recommend starting with this
one because
it's fine uh it's not great it's kind of
a very workmanlike
the cinematography is nice but you know
the dubbing
is atrocious although it's so atrocious
that it almost goes around and become
funny becomes funny again i mean like
some of the scenes
where like bruno is telling calling his
girlfriend a vacant nerd
for whatever reason and then saying
something like
is it your satisfaction to bask like a
frog in the sun or something like that
it's just all this really really weird
stuff and then there's kind of
this whole plot point about somebody
being scared of listening to tennis
balls
bouncing in the dark and stuff like that
so it's just this really weird random
[ __ ]
and like so much of the and i mean i
really really love like the
scene near the beginning where katya the
first girl like just pops out of this
dude's closet
and no one's all that alarmed about it
and she doesn't really tell
him why she's she doesn't ever tell him
why she was in there
and then she gets killed and then like
it was just very funny to me that they
kept calling that bug a cockroach even
though it was obviously a spider
so it was just like really really funny
[ __ ] like that um but i will say it's
kind of
you know there's some gore in it it's
not nearly as gory as uh
some of the other ones probably the
bathroom kill like i said is the best
one you know in
in the sense of like you know being gory
and being being kind of disturbing and
stuff but the rest of it is
pretty tame as i said maybe because i i
read some of the reviews because this is
on shutter at the moment
read some of the reviews where some
people thought like the ending was a
surprise they didn't
expect tony to be uh the killer you know
as their linda alter ego but
i kind of called that really early in
the film just because they were trying
to go out of their way to say look the
killer's a woman you know what i mean
and then they had all these other women
like turning up at this house randomly
so i was like i know it's not gonna be
any of them i know how this is gonna go
i've seen enough movies to know how this
is going to go
and indeed that is exactly how it went
so it wasn't surprising for me but again
there
there is some fun stuff about this uh
but it's a little slow to start it
doesn't really get good until probably
like the halfway point the first
part of it is fine but a lot of it is
just kind of bruno wandering around the
house
sondra coming over there creeping around
the house and trying to figure out the
mystery and whatnot
but it does have like some cool things
to recommend it you know
you could certainly do a lot worse i've
seen a lot worse ones
but you know it's not the best one
either by a long stretch
this is kind of a very middle of the
road giallo but if you've seen a lot of
the other ones
uh you know the better known ones in the
genre and you're looking for more of
that or
you know you want to see one that came
out a little bit later like i said this
is directed by
lamberto bava uh son of the much more
famous
mario baba obviously and he also
co-directed uh
demons with dario argento which is also
a good flick i'll have to do that one of
these days as well
uh because i just watched that again
recently but yeah it's
certainly uh worth your time if you're
really into
italian horror and you haven't seen it
uh i would recommend it but
just don't expect too much it's just
kind of it's it's a very middle of the
road kind of uh glo movie but it still
has
you know it's still fun it still has a
few things to recommend it
and it's not a waste of time you know
what i mean so anyway that'll do it for
this
flickers of fear and i will see you on
the next one bye